One Mighty Morphin' Power Rangers wrist watch
communicator toy was placed into the Clockworks
on the setting "Very fine."
The output produced was: The same wrist-comm.
Upon putting it on to test communications
functions, the D-class disappeared in a beam
of orange light that shot off towards the
western United States.
Satellite tracked it for 27 minutes until
it reached the Brandeis-Bardin Campus at the
American Jewish University in Simi Valley,
California, where the D-class rematerialized
and impacted the roof.
D-class terminated.
Professor Wren was baffled by this until he
looked at satellite photos of the place the
D-Class wound up.
That building was apparently used as the Command
Center in the original Power Rangers.